so this is how I because I don't know
how to loop it in later that's great
so I cheat here kid I just play it as we
talk guys Theo von
what's up guys now beautiful Tuesday
what is it instead of - dude this is how
I this is my this song every time I play
it do is the same reaction from
everybody how can you not have that
reaction right this is like urban right
here Jeffy Chaka Khan they don't have a
people don't sing like this anymore Theo
von I feel like once like we once why
people get forgiven for slavery that's
abuse on you you know what by the way
you know I listen to Uptown funk the
other day I blame uptown funk for making
every white person think they can dance
yeah like as soon as that song comes on
every white person is like oh I got to
build something for that yeah I get
little some but you know my my el town
funk is really it's a gateway drug just
somebody hurt in their sprain in their
back so why do i person out on the floor
like let's get it yeah you know what you
know what one song always tricked me
into thinking that I can dance is erotic
City by Prince that comes on I'm like oh
I think I can [ __ ] get it yeah but my
brother's wife I'm the only person in my
family you know my other two brothers
are married they both married black
women right so I'm the only one who
married a white house so I'm wearing
white I'm the only one left in the will
you know I'm saying yeah but they're but
they're there they're the only ones uh
whose children are going to hear a good
recipe and professional athlete yeah so
it's dude but my brother's wife when he
was out the he she was like I'd like to
start dancing and her advice to him was
keep it tight keep the elbows in
shoulders down
just keep it tight so that way you
always kind of look like you know what
you're doing
like a bad box yeah yeah keep it tight
every now and then if you want to bring
the hands up a little bit you can but
not too much right they said keep it all
in here and you never look too bad
that's kind of what I've stuck by really
yeah right in here man
she keeps it because this doesn't look
terrible no matter what's playing right
now yeah beach music yes
whatever you got I'm still kind of in
the groove a little bit yeah you're
still up at the wedding somebody
yeah people I do that judgment loves to
go on dance yeah I've been at tight yeah
we'll look at him older ladies like look
at him
yeah and he's and by the way she also
said don't go too fast because you can
tell when you're moving fast if you're
offbeat but if you're moving slowly it's
like you just kind of living in with me
yeah you're feeling it mmm now I like
that man
would you have dancing style no I think
I get I used to like to dance and then I
hurt my back and then I didn't like it
at the base I really like to dance when
I was younger they said his place in
Baton Rouge called tabbies blues box and
they had a big brother up there named
tabby named Erik Adam guessing and he he
was as fat as you could get you know I
mean you could if you put any more fat
in I mean his back it just slid open and
he used to play the blues and we would
go over there and dance down there in
Baton Rouge downtown well you know Jacob
went tell us you a little bit we talked
about this I remember now is Teddy's
near that what's that one place that
everybody told me to go eat downtown
Baton Rouge chimes yeah chives is it
down there there no it's more in the
downtown downtown that's kind of like
the campus downtown yeah times is this
is more downtown downtown by the river
but then he died and went out of
business but so when you dance all right
when I get out I get on some slick shoes
on some cousin Eddie's like what would
you be dancing to like like what we cuz
for me it's got to be like a ironic city
or an uptown funk to make it feel like
oh I can get this yeah like what are you
what were you I would dance with some
nelly back in the day dude I said some
legs I mean I was all legs I was afraid
to move my arms so ah you are all lower
body dancer always yeah very alarming
some Hey alarming the some dude it
almost look like a Tai Chi kind of more
looking at yes because you know when you
go low guys who go lower body also tend
to keep their face real still - yeah I
did that and that's creepy as [ __ ] yeah
because they're concentrating so much
like there's you got I mean you got that
look on your face that's really kind of
nothing movie it's like how Kevin Spacey
acts he doesn't move his face it just
moves his mouth like this oh yeah that's
what if you
Kevin Spacey like that dudes a great
actor I'm like how do you how do you
know his face hasn't moved in [ __ ] 20
years but see you went concentration up
top I bet you you probably clenched
handle oh I bet you you were a little
tight I could have and I was on creatine
yes do you know the real type that's
interesting because I never realized
were you now I'm seeing myself dance for
the first time when you're explaining it
to me and it's real all you were tech
people were active yes it's more of a
mating college more Aboriginal a lot of
feet stomping yeah like wenzer kicks a
lot of knees a lot of hip-hop a lot of
you know kind of pelvis kind of that
like because I got big ass you know I've
always had a big ass built like a you
know they said when I was young they
said think I had Down syndrome for a
long time is that big ass you know or is
that a Down syndrome trait that's a
trait popular trait and and then or oh
that I they you said the body of a black
woman you know I guess I used to have a
big ass too and that was like the black
girls in high school like you got an ass
like a yeah and I was like yeah I'll
take that
it was exciting yeah it was exciting I
took that as maybe the biggest
compliment I ever got black ol aids man
there's something I call them like ol
aids and it's somethin when black people
there's something like yeah yeah where
when you feel that black people
appreciate you or enjoy what you do for
some reason we let a lot of our I for me
anyway I find that I let a lot of my
judgment upon what is unique or cool
cool come from black people
well that's because let's not get it
twisted in popular culture a lot of what
drives cool our black black books and
what they say
style-wise clothing wise definitely
[ __ ] music well I wonder why I mean
just what I just when you just walk
Black Watch black dudes walk down the
street they just look cooler than
slobber their voices sound cooler than
ours way more comfortable in their skin
a hundred percent like you'd like to
lose and get nervous one of the ass
white people that like I don't know if
I've ever seen like a nervous black guy
who is the most confident person on the
face of the earth a large black woman
yeah I wish I walked
around with that kind of confidence and
by the way I love it and by the way if
you read my book you know that I've had
sex with some large black women Wow I'm
gonna read it dude
one of mine I need to get in there I
always wanted to have sex with I kid if
I'm being the you enter the prototype
was help Nell Carter oh yeah temporarily
yeah yeah no I always I was like a fight
doomed out okay that's all I'd give
picture and II really yeah and I always
wanted to have say there was something
about just having sex with a big black
woman body huh I just loved it and I did
I remember I was bartending in New York
and there was a girl a woman a black
woman down the end of the bar and she
was uh she got stood up on a date
oh and we were talking all night and she
had the best sense of humor dude she was
so funny she was killing me all night
but we kept joking around I would give
her some drink joking around and after
you know the bar this bar closed at
around 3:30 4:00 yeah and after when
it's closing I said hey do you want to
go get some food later after we closed
she was yeah I'll go with you sorry
Louie she's got this huge stack of
pancakes too I'm eating some eggs I mean
I baked it huh oh do we are [ __ ]
she's killing me at tale laugh and
laughing and I all I'm thinking about is
laughing and I take this huge bite of
like a hash browns or something she
takes it she's got this huge almost like
she pulled pancake on one fork Wow and
she's holding it like this and she goes
so we [ __ ] or what no yeah and I was
like or what yeah yeah where we are
Shelly's and when you see that that's
kind of advertising because you see that
hot cake and your brains almost like
it's almost like the bait and switch a
little bit oh dude both were very
appealing yeah I was like I'd like to
eat that pancake and I would like to
have sex like a beautiful day but that's
my like for for sure hundred percent but
yeah but but like you look at a guy like
Odell Beckham jr. mm-hmm he influences
Jacob yeah but I also saw a young black
key to the gym yesterday who had the
blonde on top yes
lot of that it just feels like like
black entertainers influenced white
youth and the black youth right I don't
know that there are a lot of white
entertainers that that are influencing
the black community
great question the closest we had was
probably Michael Jackson or prints you
know not prints well I think he was more
black a little touch more black hey yeah
at least in the clothing yeah might not
sammy sosa have you seen a picture him
lately it's crazy right
[ __ ] damn and so so the three callin
him white sammy sosa
is the creepiest looking dude like and i
guess in their culture from what i read
is that it that's like a neat thing you
know what do you mean did but I don't
understand how does that happen but on
skin bleaching cream you've been putting
it on at night is that what he's done
resting in Bleach yeah basically is
putting on like a layer of bleach and
he's been resting in it and then and
that's like attractive as you get older
in that culture I guess what the because
that's not like how I don't know if he
has been paying attention but I'm
looking at you that's not how you looked
right do you know what I mean like yeah
it's not like he's going white he's
going no he is going white right but why
white like yes like Blanco yeah yeah
yeah he's got a uh work in some Rouge or
something like that is not a good look
for anybody yeah he needs it is he needs
like an exterior designer he needs uh
yeah it's bizarre to me what's bizarre
about it is is is it something he thinks
that people want yeah or is it something
maybe sexual I thought like maybe he
thought this like adjust his sexual
orientation or does he like you know is
he is it that big of a thing in their
culture to take a look like because he
was a handsome guy yeah you know I
didn't I had never read that it was I
never read that it was part of the
culture yeah that's what I read is that
sometimes in their culture they'll put
the creams on because they want to you
know lighten their skin you know what I
got to tell you I asked somebody from
outside of the culture yeah not a good
look yeah that's a tough it's a tough
look to pull off let's a deceased look
yeah that's what I mean like there's two
times when that's good when you're dead
yeah and on Halloween yeah in fact
that's once a year yeah like yeah that's
right we're dead you nailed it yeah like
you know any any makeup
yeah that's pretty strong yeah but the
walking around everyday [ __ ] and it's
not like he doesn't have a little bit of
cash yeah dude has a ton of dough they
could do it every
once I just is he married you have a
family I wonder like what his circle is
like that he's clearly if your face if
you're turning yourself into salmon Sosa
yeah you have a circle of people who are
like that looks great man yeah you know
I mean that looks great yeah oh yeah
that's a good boy solid bro you going
salmon love it yeah that's not a good
look dude let's hit the clubs all your
dead bro you're almost dead you get de
los muertos let's go yes dude now people
have been asking me about our Last Comic
Standing showdown yeah and I have
something ask cuz I heard an old fighter
in the kid yeah because I just I had
never talked about it before yeah now
for those people don't know 0 and I were
on and by the way let me tell you
something and anybody who doesn't know
Theo or isn't familiar with his stand-up
how many times unsolicited in the last
six months have I told you that you're
[ __ ] killing Comedy probably about
five maybe and I appreciate it every
time man yeah the thing that keeps me
going a lot of time I'm telling you
right now as a storyteller because those
of you have seen me know that I'll tell
a 15 20 minute story yeah Joey Diaz the
other day was saying you were one of the
best one of the best when he came in
telling were the best community team
yeah I love telling stories right but I
watched you tell stories dude and am
[ __ ] in awe be one you make up words
yeah that become an integral part of you
of your story yeah and people are on
board with it 100% you have a different
cadence than I never heard anyone tell a
story and your point of view do that
hamster story yeah is like and I watched
that kind of evolve you know ever do
that do you ever get interested in
watching people other people's jokes
evolve mmm-hmm I apply hey man wanna
watch a lot I love watching how people
go because guys a joke you know I think
Joan Rivers said it jokes never finished
yeah and so there's some yeah right
never finished that's why when people
say to me oh I heard that joke I'm like
but you didn't you heard it a year ago
when I was just starting it yeah and now
it's so much better and now it's like a
little universe sometime but they don't
give you a lot of times they don't give
you that now they go but I heard it
before I'm like but just listen to it
one more time because it it was two
minutes before it's eight minutes now
yeah how do you work everything out on
stage yeah I mean I'll record it and
then throw it back up that you know I'll
record it go back and listen because
that most I learned mostly on stage
people find and unfortunately it's a
slow way to learn I find I think
sometimes it's a great way to learn but
it's also slow because you have to get
out there on the road you got to be out
there you know with these long sets so
you can have a lot of room to kind of
you know let your let your inside just
kind of spray out you know and I feel
like I feel like that's where I learned
the most so I will tell you when Beth
and I saw you so I met the EO on last
comic and I remember saying because
everybody knew you from something else
before I was a road girls cast what
started out in reality TV when I was 19
and I and I know a lot of people even at
last comic were like what just to funky
wood to smoke it yeah but I remember
telling Beth and who anyone would listen
I was like if he's this funny now
because I didn't know what your your
work ethic was like yeah stand-up is so
much people understands so much stand-up
as your work ethic
because it's repetition and figuring out
what you do well I'm sure you can tell
right now when you start to tell a story
you're like I know I can say this funny
Yeah right on a percentage finally I
know like this is so I can even just
write it you can't even have a thought
now and know that's going to be big for
me that's such a huge thing it's such a
huge hurdle where you go this word will
be funny coming out of my mouth yeah
like there are words that you could say
that people get a laugh that I could say
that won't get a laugh right but that's
what makes you different too but I
remember watching you and being like
this dude if he's got a work ethic he's
going to be [ __ ] really funny as you
are dude and nobody works harder than
you man I look at those lineups you're
onstage like you get six seven eight
sets downtown every yeah yeah man I've
done a lot of sets and I think about it
it's funny I was driving down the street
the other day and I'm like man I've done
a set in half the places on the street
whether that used to be a bar yes to be
a AAA meeting it used to be a you know
whatever was some you know a break room
in the back of a grocery store it's like
people have had the weirdest shows yeah
yeah yeah I am
and so many people just go by the
wayside it's like
it's a wild business man but I do always
appreciate there's a couple of guys you
Ian Edwards is always really nice Kirk
Fox or reach out sometimes and say nice
things just guys that do because that's
for you know guys that we're almost in
the same classroom a few years yeah yeah
groups different of comedians but like
it means a lot you know because it's
like mass it's you know it's just such a
tough business and there's so much
rejection it's funny to me man if I'm
being completely honest with you it's
funny to me that somebody that I know is
and when I say next-level funny guys
like obviously but there's burr and
those guys and but think it was like the
next group below I'm telling you go see
it but it's it's crazy to me where does
your lack of self-confidence come from
because from the outside looking in yeah
your dude who shouldn't lack confidence
all the way going all the way back to
when I first met you
yeah but you've always had a little
where do you think that comes from it
yeah I think just probably just do you
feel that yeah I do feel it sometimes I
feel a little bit less these days like
the other day I had a moment where I
didn't feel it and I could notice that
so I kind notice that I didn't feel you
know less than or like I didn't feel
unwell you know um
is it more onstage or offstage for you I
think it's more I think it bleeds on the
onstage but most of it's all staged I
think some of it came from starting out
in reality TV and thinking that and just
having such a because like you know III
did Road rules when I was 19 which yeah
MTV shows used to be super popular and
and this is a time when there was no it
was only 40 channels on television you
know it was like when MTV was hey you
yeah but we got I remember one week we
got like 14 million viewers yeah right
which is bizarre like that's Walking
Dead [ __ ] yeah that's Walking Dead
numbers yesterday so I think but then I
quit that I did that for five years and
then I just quit I just wasn't you know
kind of evolved college kind of ended
and then I got into stand-up totally
separately but I feel like this industry
is always kind of even though they say
it people in LA are so like welcoming
and like ungentle like I think it was
always just hold up you have like we're
not going to give this kid
a fair look you know and then just
recently I started realizing that that
I'm getting that that's not the case
anymore that people are giving me more
of a fair look but I think a lot of my
lack of self confidence came from and it
was even anger at first that people
weren't going to give me a fair look
yeah because I don't think I would
really hold that against someone are
just different things that happen in
their life especially like things happen
in people's childhood you know whether
it was a TV show or whether they got
abducted by aliens Judy was a gig by the
way abducted by aliens
you hold that against somebody you're
not sure I know a guy who got abducted
dude I actually know if you believe in
it do you believe in aliens bro I'm
gonna I'm gonna rink I'm gonna say I'm
going to throw five things at you okay
you ranked what you feel like the most
probable that they really exist okay
aliens hmm ghosts Bigfoot Loch Ness and
we got it I mean the other one with the
other one we got to throw in there is
the Yeti right isn't that the other one
yeah I'll go with the Yeti uh I think
ghosts for sure like they used to have a
lot of ghosts well where you're from
yeah they busted a man in our town
actually trying to be a ghost oould at
the Ramada what yeah what do you mean
this dude mr. Sweeney actually does do
cut his wiener off at a barbecue one
time on LSD and that's a true story and
this is down there in Natchez
Mississippi and I probably shouldn't be
saying it but I'm saying wait a second
nobody tried to stop him I mean that's
just not like one Queen I mean if
somebody has her dick out in a knife on
the ego near him you know that's
probably true not at first what did you
think he put it on like a cutting board
do you think he just did it out like by
the grill or what do you think he did I
know that he was operating the barbecue
at the time and I know that he was on
LSD and I know that he cut his wiener
off right in this true story you throw
it on the grill I hope not they put it
back on you know maybe to darken it up
you know they wanted just to give it a
once-over
Oh could you uh wrap it in bacon
please outdoor bacon with this sir so he
um he bounced back from that right and
this is a few years later he never bound
I mean he he got past okay there you're
thinking people accepted it
just kind of you know crazy day at the
you know at the grill and but then he
got obsessed with goats ghosting you
know doing ghost stuff yeah people that
don't exist and spirits and so they had
this Ramada in our town where and this
is back when and every models are known
for murder now when I was young it was
more of a what do you mean the Vermont
is known for murder
I mean there used to be a tumblr
actually that it was like every rumata
murder calm like every ramadas had a
murder later yeah so in that a couple
remodels under that didn't have murders
and then people got murdered if that was
wrong
so it was like finally full circle dude
this is when tumblers were a little more
pop don't they still have it I'm gonna
check that Vermont a Yelp reviews
yeah dude oh it gets really had a third
floors always closed down for murder do
it at a Ramada
always bro oh wait like is that America
a family like I know that's a gram
brother Grandma's dope I know that's
come on a hot gram yeah turn down turn
down for what I can put on some pity
cinema it's my program up here you know
and there's always some like
prostitution and stuff like models of
change when I was young they were John
Senden ramadas Holiday Inns were
beautiful you know now our Johnson
wouldn't when I was growing up Howard
Johnson was fancy yeah other orange roof
oh come on dude met a nice restaurant
attached to this oh who was getting the
restaurant attached to come on now
listen it didn't take me it took me a
little bit so I was older to realize
when you open the door to your hotel
room you don't want to be outside right
you almost you want still be inside our
Sylvia's ass to go you whatever you get
doesn't matter how much you pay but when
you open that door you won't be you
won't be inside you want to be already
be inside somewhere you want to be going
mm yeah you want to go inside inside
outside maybe even through a lobby
another inside get out you don't want
all outside all outside unless you're on
the beach fall outside is not yeah all
outside tovahleh yeah you don't want to
go inside right out yeah you want to go
inside inside kind of inside outside
yeah yeah yeah that's true yeah so you
can really count how you're doing really
on the level of inside yeah yeah if you
go like inside inside
and then you need to get another door to
go to a lobby then you're inside and
then another inside or you're in the
fancy [ __ ] place yeah dude you're uh
you're actually at that point you might
be in somebody's house kidnapped yeah
yeah he's gonna be being held hostage
but dude straight inside outside yeah
that's a bad why that's a bad if when
you open the door somebody can't see the
television because of the time right
yeah by the way if when you open the
door and you take one step and you can
jump into the pool not good that's a
[ __ ] nuts your daddy's going to join
the living room into the deep in y'all
so put the Swan floating in the deep end
y'all back up oh yeah dude why is he
doing any time when somebody's doing
some ignorant in the south people always
like y'all back up you know and everyone
takes half a step back I'm gonna be
close how far back but I thought I want
to miss it
there the south like what I've found and
I think it's great like the stories you
have now grown up the south are not
unique to their unique to you but our
stories like that all over all over all
over the south the stories that best
friends tell me about go I'm just like
blown away just buy more of these I'll
tell you what I really admire about it
is that it's not that the people in the
South raising the kids didn't care about
their kids they just let him go out and
be kids which lets with a group other
kids right there wasn't that look the
reason that there was that they're gonna
learn everything from me yeah and there
wasn't also that fear-based rate you
weren't raised you weren't raised in
fear that if you left the house you were
gonna die yeah you leave the house buy
yourself some bad [ __ ] Scott this Jacob
when he was 10 maybe 11 we lived here
and you know Studio City of the park
that's a mile and a half away yeah in
Studio City yeah does it get wider in
the studio city yeah it's the widest
place in America oh my god yeah so wide
so I was he was like he at me and I'm
like I said kid's name want to go to the
park
I said that's cool
I said they both the kid had his bike
here and he said you should call my mom
just to make sure it's okay for us to
bike there and I was like okay and and I
call her I just so you know the kids are
gonna bike to the park and she said are
you going with him I go no I'm not going
to park yeah
there are almost 12 yeah and she was
like well they can't beat the park by
themselves I'm like why not she's like
what's gonna happen to him but what if
somebody kidnaps a Mike in Studio City
yeah who a producer yeah yeah I gotta
kidnap him take him what am I gonna do
you do you pick him em hot yoga yeah
good I mean come on
but she would not she was like now and
she was like listen I'll pick them up
and drive them over I'm like I don't
want you driving my son over the point
is I want him on his bike doing some
[ __ ] on his own yeah so he gets a little
bit of confidence
you know what I mean and a little
independence I mean you didn't when you
left the house at 10:00 or 11:00 do you
leave the house oh yeah man I remember
once we had a bike about like 7:00 we
could go ride you know within like four
blocks it was like an area that we kind
of couldn't go but we really could and
you had your little group of friends
right yeah we had like two or three
people and you just kind of ride around
and just go ride through the ditches and
you know you had to be careful for cars
that was a scariest thing was the cars
no I did you grow up near a swamp at all
and batteries not too far I grew up
probably with some like rivers more and
stuff by us that would get a little
swampy in some areas but you know maybe
six miles from or like a good swamp I
always found it because Beth and her
family they're like we swam with small
cones yeah and she was like we swam in
ponds that we knew had alligators in him
I'm like what do you mean yeah she's
like it was just
we knew the alligators were there but
they never bothered us I'm like that's
not something that would have happened
near Boston yeah go get in the lake with
the alligator [ __ ] you
not even a mop nobody's going swimming
but it was like a non-issue for her yeah
but for you guys to like a non-issue
yeah well mostly alligators eat at night
right we're like around sunset so you
know you could be out in waters and
stuff like that
ditch ditch swimming was big when I was
young when it would rain a lot the
ditches would fill up and people just
swim in the ditch you had you know as a
child you had a suddenly had a three and
a half foot pool right there
you know that was four foot across and
then when those would go down I remember
all these scallions we grow I think
that's what the called scallions what
are those they're like onions yeah yeah
like yeah ditch onion so people would
pop all of those out of the ditch do
people eat the digital yo yeah yeah you
know what I don't know I see but they
were good well you know they because I'm
not sure how organic that was pretty
organic I feel like I'm we were pissing
in there yeah yeah that's what your
organism is dude I also what I love
about the south is I like and through
best family you know what is eaten and
not eaten yeah like what is eaten a lot
of time but some of the folks like on
the pig or the cow is every [ __ ]
thing yeah
every but you're eating ditch onions my
mom wouldn't let me eat blackberries
from the side of the road Wow she's like
what they were a lot of people need a
Muranos because there was just racial
discrimination really then we want to go
live for us they're not for us therefore
the yeah yeah the white people when we
get the white berries yeah we'll get our
and oh we going on any white berries
yeah but uh but no that's ingest but
yeah man I remember did that a couple
brothers mommy used to grill up dove all
the time eating does you know just grill
up some duck what else you ever had
squirrel my by overhead squirrel no
raccoon I've had squirrel before no I
haven't had raccoon I've had guinea pig
I mean I should sell hamsters and guinea
pigs I know it you know that and I've
had and when I dove eventually I satin
ate ate a little bit of dove how was it
my brother-in-law deleted oh yeah ah I
wouldn't I'd have it you wouldn't order
like if it was out repeated to a lady
you know all right but if there was that
Hugo's tacos you wouldn't be like let me
get three Dove taco no one does Hawk
what just to kind of mix it in yeah one
dove one pork yeah I had squirrel
because I was like I'm gonna try it and
the guy was like it tasted like rabbit
you know and I don't mind rabbit it's a
little gamey but but uh I'm gonna tell
you some right now
it does not taste like rabbit yeah no it
tastes like we're like a rabbit on
message let's taste like do you know to
be like it's not like it's a real tough
chew is it oh my
God you have using the squirrel right
yeah not a whole lot of meat on the
squirrel and it's mostly muscle except
the ones that live in my front yard oh
yeah there was a like owls not a lot of
meat on owls I had family at two owls
for Thanksgiving last year get the [ __ ]
out of here swearing they had weight
well how do you day hunted owl at night
during the day they're ghosts yeah I
guess I mean I don't honestly know how
they one of them I know that they had is
a pet for a long time and then another
one owls are violent first of all yeah
dude whoever pet hell yeah I'm sick of
people giving owls all this fictional
credit as they saw it on cartoons where
they're magical in the reading and [ __ ]
North a library dude owls are violent
but I will kill a lot of small animals
wigs dude go read online how many wigs
have been stolen by owls do get at it
yeah
owls are extremely violent animals I'll
say some I'm not a lot of meat on them
though they look meaty but they're not
they're just fluffy yeah it's an
illusion dude but that's why there's a
good Harry Potter yeah that's holy I
smoked too much weed to have an animal
that can turn its head all the way
around yeah if I walked in and I had an
animal that could turn it all his head
all the way around I was high and it did
that to me I'd be like [ __ ] you you are
gone dude we had a rabbit that I rescued
right we found the rabbit that we had it
was limping as one of its legs was
broken so I was like [ __ ] man I can't
just I'm an [ __ ] maybe they're trying
to make a lucky rabbit's foot you ever
think about that well dude so we save it
and I'll go through this quickly because
I'm sure some people have heard this we
save it best named it Kevin Bacon
because it's foot with loose Oh funny
right but we ended up cutting off they
had to amputate the leg but I did ask
the vet I'm like can I can I have the
foot yeah and she was like why I'm like
well I heard those are lucky and she
said well not not for him apparently and
I was like yeah I go but can I have it
and she said something to me dude that I
bet you she's never had to say before
but it made complete sense yeah we're
not in the habit of giving away dead
animal limbs and I was like yeah that
makes complete sense with yeah yeah
that's probably not something that you
want to just start giving away
cutoff animal limbs right here only yeah
I guess if you only need it
Wow who would need it I mean I think in
other times you know usual about 50
years you're gonna get that sure but
then she told me she said to order it
online and I was like you but those
aren't real and she said no this is real
did you know the ones that were 7-eleven
when we were growing up it to be real oh
wow can you imagine selling a real
animals foot my brothers and I and then
when she told me that I almost threw up
dude because my brothers and I used to
pick our teeth for the Soto and I was
like oh she was at the real toenail and
she said you know back then they weren't
cleaning them that well another oh my
[ __ ] god dude that's amazing
real feet I was crazy to think you can
go in with several enemy get real
rabbits feet not anymore
yeah there's no way I not an Ellen not
in California no [ __ ] no I bet some
places you could where you're from more
roadside stops regional wherever they
sell Larry the Cable Guy potato chips
yeah definitely all those comedy albums
at the register those are the places of
those places Kevin a lot of southern
comedy in business man
dude they're always attached to a show
nice yeah that Shoney's these have dudes
blowing each other behind a show need by
us really yeah drug addicts me me the
showings your men would meet up there's
a kind of like a this is back before now
like if you're gay it's real it seems
really easy to be gay you know I mean I
know there's a lawyer easier easier yeah
a lot of people that you know uh you
know I don't know the struggle you know
I mean I'm a I thought I may have you
know more of a late onset homosexuality
when I'm probably maybe 60 or 70 you
know but I want to have a wife and
children and everything first you and
then maybe around 60 dabble in the dick
maybe 70 70 at that point I'm sure at
that point is it even gay or is it just
like you know let's just see grab balls
[ __ ] yeah yeah go for the crazy guy well
dude have you ever done a threesome with
two dudes and a girl no see that's where
I was always never interested in that
yeah because one is very Roman yeah and
I'm assuming I know the guy right and I
don't need that I don't need to see his
face I'm never going to be able to come
looking at my buddy the urban that's a
tough one for me I had friends who loved
it they were like it we high-five I'm
like
yeah I don't know if I would do that in
then I guess I mean I think there was a
couple of opportunities where I could
have got involved in it but I guess for
some reason I passed
so I guess something and I wouldn't
enjoy it because I chose not to get into
it dude I do this a lot but I want to
know about the dude ghosting at your
Ramada oh yeah so this dude's wienie so
then they didn't have this for that
elevators you know back when you know if
you were handicapped you just kind of
wait at the bottom of the stairs and
people would bring you you know if you
had nice people and I think probably
good way to meet people respect him but
but say about that oh yeah I think
elevators take a lot of the
interpersonal communication out of the
world yeah and also I mean it wet I
would not be staying on the top floor
anymore yeah that first floor would now
be hot hot right who wants the penthouse
give you that [ __ ] first floor corner
room yeah yeah yeah be nice yes so he
this dude was obsessed with getting this
remodel on like the National Ghost
registry right for haunted places in the
universe or whatever you know like those
ghosts like you know senior citizens go
on busses and go around the country
riding ghosts you know we look for them
so they wanted this he was obsessed with
getting this room out on there and so
upstairs the rooms were directly across
from each other along this long hall
the doors were directly across from each
other so he would rent the last two
rooms of the hallway hoping each door
dress up in his ghost stuff what's his
ghost stuff of teasing just like a white
yes I'm quieter kind of beige sheets
maybe like an X all or something and
then he would wait until people came to
the top of the stairs at the other end
of the hallway and they're walking down
it and he would walk from one room
across the hallway into the other one
because both doors are open right far
away from so they just see a ghost
literally crossed the hallway oh [ __ ]
and it was work and like people were
thinking what year what year you think
this is this is probably
90 so before people were like that's
fake that was still right in you see it
you believe it yeah well I'd in the
middle that yeah and it was a pretty
good thing it wasn't like you know he
just had a sheet with drawn on eyes like
it was very far away it was extremely
quick I could see that it sure and
especially if you already fear town
there's not much going on sure yeah
let's up let's get a go and especially
if somebody has said hey the Ramada is
haunted yeah one time is all it takes
you want art you want that [ __ ] so did
he get caught he didn't get caught for
probably a year year and a half and I
don't know how much he was doing it but
I mean the Ramada staff had to know
right because they rented him - yeah the
Ramada was onto it right right well he
was in cahoots I think part of his
family owned the Ramada
so he had some fiscal reward probably
from it back end if you see it ghost at
the end of the hallway
yeah and you think you really see a
ghost do you walk down to the end of the
hallway or do you turn the [ __ ] around I
think you turn around especially back
then
oh yeah a hundred percent I turn around
yeah I know I know some people were like
I'm going to see the ghost yeah nope
yeah that's a lot of people that
probably are looking to die yeah people
to watch TLC and [ __ ] like yeah you know
yes for me like the shows on TV aren't
real yeah but like the real ghosts and I
and so you think ghosts when we're
ranking them number one yeah I think I'm
with you I think ghosts a hundred
percent are real and I think the more
you believe in them the more apt they
are to know you're open you know I used
to watch this show paranormal active
activity whatever was at the movie but
it was a paranormal show where this dude
would go in and the thing and he would
chase demons and best doesn't bite
hundred demons like on yeah not like
demons like I got a bad kamilly habit
like I like demons like okay yeah yeah
like demons yeah his s people yeah and
he would say demons look for people who
believe in it or who who are into that
world because it's easier for them to
attack some dude now you know I smoke
weed and walk around my neighborhood
yeah dude I can't drive past any
furniture without hanging up you ugly
have you ever just put a couch on the
side of the road dude I literally cannot
see any piece of furniture feather or
without thinking everything it is it's
the mitts the craziest thing but I just
drove by yesterday I'm like that
oh dude my favorite one happened like a
month ago where I was like oh [ __ ] look
at all this good stuff dude and then as
I'm walking out I see a woman putting
stuff out I'm like are you moving and
she goes he is and I was like oh when he
was gone she has taken all of his [ __ ]
and started so I posted that one I was
like hey dude I don't know who you are
but if any of this looks familiar
I come get it right Wow yeah dude yeah
yeah yeah I am fascinated by people just
I don't want it anymore and just putting
it out on the street like who does that
[ __ ] well they used to do it a lot
people would burn it you know and that
have ditch fires was a big thing getting
all your stuff outside burning it you
know like that was big and that's still
big in more rural area yeah in the city
you can't do that you know there's
limits to start they frown upon starting
flowers on the side of the house yeah
but the curvature is like there's you're
out there you're in that word Ormond I'm
oh I'm in those streets dude are you
kidding and they're like a Wyatt Earp of
awe of old furniture there is some just
ridiculous like I love it when people
believe it out and leave a sign that
says free oh really if you didn't need
me to this wasn't all I thought we were
some sort of transaction I was waiting
for you to come out I had some cash I
was going to barter with you seeing as
how my dog just [ __ ] on your chair do
you know of course it's free yeah I get
it yeah
totally get free not a sign I need it
yeah I'm not putting in on this yeah
yeah oh really
wait here's out there on a board is
yelling for them to come out like the
free will you want to discuss it was it
uh have a couple questions how much for
this one yeah there's a Nick on the
corner yeah how much for this one are
you gonna deliver what he has yeah well
how was surreal to my place yeah so did
that you find some of the most one dude
who put his a table out had forgotten to
empty his drawers
so I always looked kind of fascinating
yeah he had like he had there were some
old corn packages in there who we are he
had so his remote controls or I was like
huh my heat these yeah this dude Gahan
was lying on this table anymore and now
he's high looking around his whole
apartment like where's my [ __ ] remote
Yankee even work is he with that remote
or Lina ultimate do when I was growing
up my dad refused to get a remote yeah
here's a I don't want you getting lazy
I'm like this is gonna do lazy but like
I got to get up and change the channel
every time and he said I really don't
need a remote anyways I'm like why he's
like I got you I might get that's the
[ __ ] chair dude I'm your remote
that's awesome that's like when Jacob
there was one day where I try to explain
to people all the time if you live in
California somebody does your lawn yeah
it's not like a rich thing right do you
know what I mean
right it really isn't it's just somebody
does your lawn it's how it always is
it's like they're like you don't pay
that much it's like a Walmart of lawn
people right they do a shit-ton lawn of
the day and they don't charge you right
but there was one week our guy couldn't
come
and I tell Jacob I go hey I rigged up
some leaves yo he was just like what and
he goes don't we don't we don't like
have people and I was like well you mean
people man and I could see him
struggling with it and he was like well
you know like uh you know that Mexican
guy and I go dude you're my Mexican yeah
you understand yeah get out and rake the
leaves like I used to be the thing dude
i raked didn't you mow lawns
oh yeah dude I remember you make money
grown-up well I just saw hamsters for my
first job used to clean out wishing
wells I got a job clean not wishing
wells one time wait what did I do with
that money
well they had a man in our town who
tricked me my friend said it was his
Wells right he had two well did two
wells in our town dry wells huh big
holes in the ground but you know kind of
the stonework in the circle kind of deal
and people would wish and I'm throw
money in there but there's a lot more
psychic Goonies yeah just like that kind
of but without like a universe of
treasure down Oh
oh yeah good stuff yeah without people
walking through or some you know a
chance to look at some change yeah it's
you know so we would go down me and my
buddy
and he had two learning deficiencies
anyway but he was like the closest
person to me so we were friends you know
but we would go down there and we could
keep like I think it was maybe 25% of
whatever we pulled up right but most of
stuff in wishing wells it's not wishes
dude it is trash recyclables you know
chairs fingers I do too what's here
what's crazy is so where we kind of
bloody sword one time and we played with
it like three weeks and this [ __ ]
threw it away dude and hindsight
probably was a weapon I'm hitter what's
called evidence yeah yeah yeah yeah but
uh we not as much money do you get down
in the water how deep is it there's
probably 10 12 feet and there will be a
little water at the bottom uh-huh
maybe it was a teat maybe it felt like
12 feet then you know but to a child
things feel deeply drowned so like maybe
eight or yeah maybe a turd 851 I when
people weren't making as many wishes
like I don't know you know what the over
time the when people are most likely to
wish you know yeah years wise you know
like that 70s were a huge time for
people how much you're telling up out
there I mean I remember the mostly
pulled was probably like $18 or
something like it was a complete waste
of time
dude there's nothing worse than planning
some sort of crime and not getting what
you thought you're going to get yeah
Joey Diaz and I robbed a safe once
really oh yeah and we thought honestly
forty to sixty thousand dollars easy Wow
easy 40 rows of money okay so this is
good did I like thinking about this I
was I worked at a bar in Seattle
the dude who ran it was a [ __ ] thief
sold a lot of coke I've been working for
him for three months he hadn't paid me
it I had Oh
one slashed run the place that was there
before so he's like man if you'd stay on
to help us get it up and running so when
your customers come in they see you so
we keep them all the stuff and I was
like cool and he was like and you can
pick whatever bartending shift you want
and we'll pay you you know every every
two weeks the manager and I like cool
Wow we went three months no money and
I'm watching these guys they're they're
stealing money from the till oh yeah
they're it's been I'm like I didn't drop
money on drugs oh yeah
so I'm like all right well I'm getting
mine yeah we've gone three months and
I've run this place as clean as I
possibly can with with you [ __ ]
so I'm like I'm gonna I'm gonna take my
money plus I'm gonna get a lecture yeah
so it was Yankees weekend Yankees
Mariners I've worked downtown forever
that's forty to sixty thousand dollars
Friday Saturday nobody's going to the
bank on Saturday nobody goes the bank on
Sunday right you go on Monday yeah so
it's he big loop man yeah I tell Joe hey
I'm out of town I never kind of respect
me yeah here's the key to the back go in
the back but make it look like you broke
in Wow do went in we had another dude
with us that Joey called Frankie the lip
oh my because I used to develop this
huge pimple mm-hmm that he called a
pimple but I was a given to the pimple
keeps coming back it has not a pimple
yeah yeah but we kept away we can let
them keep the pimple really simple that
keeps on panthan yeah that's a pimple
you can give to somebody yeah that's not
a pimple yeah yeah I said so might go uh
he had Frankie the lip with him was
[ __ ] getaway dude mmm Joey gets up
grab so you you were you worried when
they go into this because you're just
like you're out of town I was in I was
in Moscow Idaho doing stand-up so you're
just like you get off the phone with him
like all right let's see what happened
he I went through the whole thing right
and he gets safe it's heavy
he calls me from the car this
[ __ ] so every we'll rich just
wolf we are rich what's the combination
I'm like I don't really know the
combination he's like
what and he's like I go I think I know
and I gave giving it to him I must have
given it to him wrong cuz I thought I
knew it he couldn't open it I took a
little while to open it he called me
maybe two hours later you're not getting
[ __ ] I go why he was twenty eight
thousand quarters in quarters like a
wishing well dude the crooks didn't
trust each other
oh hey two owners they were both
stealing so one of the owners got in 20
minutes before Joe and cleared out the
safe and cleared out like forty five
fifty thousand dollars but like we had
planned you know we were we we were all
ready when he called me he was like oh
there's so much money in here just mope
oh my god
oh we're gonna be rich and like he was
so [ __ ] mad he's like me and the lip
are splitting this [ __ ] money do you
think he told you the truth about how
much was in there do you think he took
it I do think he told me the truth
because I saw how he lived afterwards
right and um and I'm not discrediting
Joey I'm just saying at that time you
know who knows what was going well I
always considered Joey to be a moral
criminal yeah okay so what I mean by
that
yeah a hundred percent he's stolen a
twenty dollar bill off the table from me
at my house yeah but then he took me out
to lunch with it right and he was like I
got it this time I'm like no really the
guy I kind of got it but he was like you
know the guy it's your money yeah yeah
yeah okay
but but uh yeah man when you think
you're getting the heist of all heists
hmm you come away with twenty eight
dollars in quarters yeah that's a
[ __ ] when you go down in the
well and you're like I'm finding gold
yeah this is where she Irish jean
lafitte measured he buried his treasure
kid we thought there were any two dis
jewels who thought jewels dude we've
never even seen jewel do so I've still
never seen any jewel it but the lore of
jewels when are twelve you know we're
just kidding small Allen - it was over
they would [ __ ] go this [ __ ] with
this small alum yeah dude
this dude was he wasn't he was like I'm
I don't see was a [ __ ] dude he was
like a [ __ ] with like gigantis ism you
know like he's like biggest of the small
people yeah and he looked was he all
size in
because little people can get all sides
and elbows sometimes he was just about
60% of a regular person you know they
call it a small Alan but his dad
actually was like kind of Slavic or
something he used to have his dad could
would get and this is like I know if
some people this might sound a little
pedia filing and stuff like that but I
this wasn't like that this is back not
everybody who just pulled her junk out
around children was PDF files you know I
have an uncle that would run through the
living room naked on Christmas Eve and
it wasn't Christmas Eve until he did
that you know like it wasn't wait what
was he wearing it did he have a Santa
hat on naked no I'm [ __ ] no dude he
had drug issues and he's to masturbate
in his sleep but uh but it wasn't
Christmas until that happened and we
weren't like oh what oh you know we're
just like he's [ __ ] up dude
Santa's coming thank God yeah crazy
right it was like Groundhog Day yes it
was just yet how is he a part of the
festivity yeah his dick his dick said
there's going to be another two days
before Christmas a well small Allen had
a little brother on remembers brother's
name and the dad used to be in like I
want to say vaudeville but something
like that but in like Romania or
something they were from they were like
gypsies you know their handlers gypsies
well his brother dad would the kid would
grab onto like the dad would have his
pants down the kid could grab onto the
top of his penis and balls and fully
lift his less violent could know his
brother his little brother dude I'm even
littler Gerald I don't even know his own
name I remember you know but small
Alan's brother would grab onto the nuts
and hang from his dad's penis and nuts
dude and the dad was totally okay bro
well that's like some [ __ ] slavic
circulation yeah so there's very very
old-school very Russian you know very
that that's what the 18th century kind
of [ __ ] you know at one point in his
family someone was on a high wire with
one of those big dicks and they're like
bring out small Alan in small Alan hey I
would hang by his nuts and they would
walk across him you know like that was
like what their family is known for is
that is the nut hanger yeah if the kid
falls off you die you know like
dude I get it really fascinating and we
didn't think the dad was because the dad
wasn't trying to be a pervert it didn't
seem like just the vine nothing sexual
about us about anybody hanging on to
your nuts and just swinging by them
there's nothing sexual about that going
that's true that's that's some circus
[ __ ] like that's some [ __ ] where you're
like yeah and look if they if I was in
Vegas and that was at a Cirque de Soleil
show I'd be out yeah that's [ __ ]
really good how did you learn like how
do you learn whenever I hear [ __ ] like
that though Theo my first question is
how do you learn Matt - Talent yeah you
know I mean like how do you be what's
the first person you said you want why
don't you try hanging on my nuts yeah
that's my that's always my question when
people have talents like that that's a
good point I think it's I always think
like it starts smaller you know what I
mean like like he like clamps something
to his nuts and it kind of hung down
like okay yeah like a kettlebell like
al-qaeda digger in a kettlebell yeah
like a couple of yeah like a like maybe
had those sausages that are hooked by
like the you know the middle part is
hung a couple of those yeah yeah yeah I
just see and you just to kind of test it
out a little bit music this isn't that
bad he's like I'll move up and I'll take
a coffee cup that has like a little like
a handle on it yeah and it helps to
address and every now and then I got a
full coffee cup of sand all right well
yeah small child getting out Alan let's
see yeah yeah those are the days man
dude he is different man do you keep in
touch with your old friends from home um
yes um actually just saw a kid last week
and I think he has Asperger's I didn't
realize there were children because
everybody's having a good time so some
dude was just yelling [ __ ] out yes I'm a
party and it was like kind of cool but
uh what did he yell [ __ ] out oh he came
to a comedy show right a friend of mine
and I hadn't seen him in 20 years funny
guy really really funny nice dude but
literally every two minutes at the show
he had to kind of yell something out
like he was and it wasn't even these
part of the show it of realizing he had
an issue he had something wrong with
gist and thinking back him he always
drove me drove everybody a little bit
nuts were young
but he was handsome guy he was cool and
he was that bloody he was just a regular
do but he also drove everybody nuts and
I realized wow this guy has some you
know a hit of the Tisza more something
Menem that's really handsome due to
making him making the squirrels run
inside of his skin you know but uh but
it was still good to see him but I don't
know if I'd invite him back to my comedy
show again we he was a little vocal yeah
is you know does yelling [ __ ] like I
would it hurts it hurts his or
entertainer because you're on a you're
you're playing your song yeah I'm time
do you like it when the crowd talks to
you I don't mind it if I don't mind it
too much but if it gets out of hand or
if they're being really negative I don't
like it because I won't be negative with
them I used to be like I'll [ __ ] this
you know whatever I don't do that
anymore I try to show them respect I
hope they do the same you know I depends
on what night you catch me yeah that's a
good point
some nights I don't even depend on a lot
some nights because people forget I'm
not only am i doing my job but I'm also
a person yeah so some nights I don't
want to deal with you talkin and now I I
don't go in on you at first out it's not
like that for me I'll say something like
hey listen guys a lot of people here
everyone paid you're you're just so you
know no one paid to hear you talk yeah
so uh I'm tonight did tonight's just not
the night i preciate it if you just
quiet it down because if you don't it's
just not gonna end well yeah for you
especially yeah it's gonna end pretty
well for me not so wealthy and so but
some lights I like playing with people
you know what I do is what I don't like
if you're in the first couple rows you
have your phone out we got a problem
Wow we got a problem because it's where
I work right and to sit up front where I
can see you not paying attention to me
to me is just comply listen we I don't
doesn't seem like it sometimes but we
work hard on our jokes and on our crap
yeah so if you sit down in front of me
it's like turning your back to me yeah
can't can't can't do it
yeah that's true that would hurt some
man
and I see it sometimes I don't mind if
somebody gets up in leaves and goes
either right yeah I don't mind I don't
want to sit there and that lights
glowing and you're just you're out
you're just doing one of your you know
favorite bits or something they're just
sitting there don't even give up not one
[ __ ] about what you're saying
and they even little they laugh at a
text that they get said of your joke you
know yeah I'm like though
[ __ ] no you talking about I brought
these jokes from you know I flew these
joke 1,600 miles yeah this is not for
you to [ __ ] turn on your phone dude
you didn't tell me are we going to tell
me though you're going to tell me
something about Last Comic Standing
oh so I cheated yeah so Theo and I were
the last to last comics downloaded right
you know they had a competition they had
like a head-to-head almost like a Final
Four if you will NCAA right then they
have 40 people that were going to be
potentially could be on Last Comic
Standing and so you face to face with
each other and Theo and I ended up being
you know face to face on the internet
and this one the internet was just so
kind of just to get it yeah this my face
is my space time oh yeah so I had a
friend of mine who worked in computers
and he goes hey man do you want to win
and I said yeah and he goes I can set up
a program that just gives you a vote
like every minute and I'm like really
for all of them he goes yeah for every
single competition you do he goes I'm
pretty sure you went we got to the
finals dude yeah but my man couldn't can
I still couldn't beat you even though I
was cheating that's crazy and I didn't
even know I was i I wondered if I would
ever tell that story but nobody gives a
[ __ ] now nobody gives a [ __ ] and you
know you know the one thing I hated
about that show even though I like doing
it at the time and by the way it was the
first time I'd ever seen Josh blue that
he blew me away yeah because I had never
heard anyone be like do that but I
remember calling him a prop comic yeah
and the audience was like boohoo
because I followed him and I was trying
to I find the best way to follow
somebody like that is to just poke fun
yeah like if we were on stage and I was
gonna follow you ever follow Joey Diaz
to the Comedy Store yeah she's a fifteen
minutes of him on fire yeah he's like
it's like it's like literally a fire
being in the room you
it's relentless when he hits it and
especially for 15 minutes throw oh my
god and you're just back there going
holy [ __ ] so I would follow him by
telling a story that kind of make fun of
him but that's the way to do it right so
I followed Josh and I remember I've
roomed with him and I remember him
saying whoever has to follow me is in
trouble
Wow five minute to me is in trouble
because five minute to him was really
two and a half minutes with the [ __ ]
ovations and the yeah and that's the
first like or the early times when they
had people that had disabilities yeah
that's one tell yes like you know
America's Got Talent head and come out
and like milk to that thing yeah now
they're throwing like three headed
people okay and it's like telling three
different jokes at once yeah somebody
has no parents like this this boy has no
parents dude never did this boy appeared
we found him in a tree yeah we found him
in a tree man his dad's his dad is a is
a squirrel his dad the squirrel and his
mother is a bougainvillea you know it's
just like this is all [ __ ] he's got
three heads yeah
seven fingers yeah and they're all
coming out of his belly button yeah
it is saying one of them has a gambling
problem it's so funny any reality show
now like if you don't have a sob story
you're like the only one i watch and I
watch it with best as I'll watch the
voice and sometimes when somebody with a
good voice comes on but their story is
just they're 21 and they have a great
family and their story is just I just
want it really bad I'm like she's got no
shot yeah like nobody I just want a real
bad girl is not beating you know my dad
is a squirrel yeah and my mom has seven
singers in her bellybutton everyone's
like I'm [ __ ] yeah I got a vote for
the belly better not know how to read
yes
yeah you better have some like there
better be something naughty really bad
yeah that comes out where people like
well we got a vote for this she don't
eat hamsters sir so you brought me here
to apologize to them right I brought you
here to apologize and to tell you well I
don't get apologize you wanna [ __ ]
obviously
effective our judges you wondered I was
just happy to be in the contest you know
I was happy to even be in the contest I
was happy we have your my name next to
your name in any association I was just
excited to be and then we went to Lake
Charles and we put on a show we had no
business putting on in like a 10,000
seat arena arena allowed to be sold
maybe on 50 tickets I remember because
my wife's had no idea how it really
worked right she was like well you guys
were on TV
so we'll rent out the arena and we were
like I was like okay I said are you sure
we're gonna be able to fill that she was
like you were just on TV everybody
watched Last Comic Standing and nothing
comes to Lake Charles everybody's gonna
want to come to meet the guys on TV and
I was like okay and she was like make
sure you get Theo and then we had bucked
and flip honey hand flips you know we
thought flip was homosexual of it yeah
anybody's not he's not even married now
and he might have late onset
homosexuality like I do
yeah he has those kind of we have very
small hands yes
that way that can lead you to believe
that yeah if somebody sets a small hand
in your hand and genteel yeah not a hand
not a heavy shayla's yeah lay so smooth
I just wanted to rub one of his hands in
between mine although it's almost like
he bought his hands at an antique yeah
dude so nice right antique hands but I
remember we did that radio spot if we
hadn't done that radio spot there would
have been eight people at that show yeah
it was a giant plane was it I barely
remember dude I don't remember that well
it's where Larry the Cable Guy pay
played two weeks before it was in her
it's there downtown its massive maybe
5,000 really dude we sold like 120
tickets and then we went out to try sell
merch afterwards and people were just
not having that [ __ ] at all that was the
craziest that's when I realized I don't
think I know that much about what's
happening in stand-up right because that
was before I was touring with cable guy
right and so I didn't really even
realize wow we got what tour with him
that's amazing oh dude it was the he's
been nicest yeah I've always heard nice
things
him 379 punchlines in his set we counted
them one night 370 it's what it's like
when people when I hear young comics
make fun of Cable Guy or Foxworthy I'm
like you don't get it yeah you know get
it first of all you wish your career is
a quarter of the success yeah a quarter
of the success but Foxworthy has the two
highest-grossing comedy albums of all
time
yeah say what you want you may not think
he's funny that dude is a great comic a
hundred percent and I wonder why they
haven't like why hasn't the the comedy
world embraced or Hollywood embrace more
like southern or kind of rural community
they've done a long time because there
have been 25 years portrayed is dumber
you know look I don't care what you say
whether somebody's humor is dumb or not
stand if you're a good stand-up you're
not dumb yeah comedy agree if you're a
good stand-up comedian you're not stupid
yeah there's just no way writing a joke
is not something a stupid person does
well yeah it's a difficult thing and
then to master it now they may not talk
the same way and cable guy a lot of that
is an act everybody but to roll out 379
punchlines and there for a while dude
when I toured with him I told him for
four years and he had a new hour and a
half three times over those four years
he you know I say which and I worked
with Foxworthy on fifth-grader well I
wrote jokes for him but the only reason
I took that job dude and I told my age
and I go tell Jeff I'll take the job if
he gives me a half an hour a day to pick
his brain about stand-up dude it was
fascinating you know he used to get up
at 4:00 in the morning when he was
starting going to his garage and call
radio stations all around the country
and that's how he got you might be
redneck stuff and he just built up his
name back when radio really did right
but he would do it from 4:00 to 8:00
every morning sickness garage he would
tell me calling radio stations all
around the country all during drive time
you know as they get later he came
across and he sat in smoked cigarettes
and drank coffee did it for four hours
every [ __ ] morning
every morning dude and and like he was
no fluke in his stand-up I went and
watch a stand-up a couple years ago at
the Ryman in Nashville still awesome
come on man you know what the confidence
it takes to speak at his pace not swear
to never yell to never raised his voice
and to still hold an audience for an
hour and a half that takes how long did
it take you to get comfortable with
silence on stage
I'm just even enjoying that more now
it's silence because silence I equate it
more now we're just listening kind of
yeah and silence is almost like an
instrument that you're playing a little
bit when they're silent if they're if
you know there's a punch line coming and
they don't really know or they don't
know what direction it's going to go
then that's really like a it's almost
like you're walking on a tightrope you
know yeah but you know that you're gonna
you that's what they think you know that
you don't but you don't know how you're
gonna survive yeah but you know that
you're about to cut the rope and turn it
into like a rope swing you know the
great description dude because that's a
thing like you you're leading them down
a path but they have blinders on yeah
like they can't see where you're leading
them yeah and then you take off the
blindfold and you're like haha you're
like what's go bug I never knew we were
gonna be here with your grandma yeah
dude do you and now I used to but I
don't anymore like I can't get on stage
higher drunk no I don't yeah I don't
even drink anymore quit drinking about a
year ago how's that going it's going
great man I love it I love not did you
had you hit a bad spot I mean I had some
crazy times but I remember one time I
was going to Opie and Jim Norton Show
and I was in New York City and this I
mean that show had a million listeners
ahead of its height and I remember going
and I stayed up all night partying and I
got in there and I was not in any kind
of good condition and and like Darryl
Strawberry was in there wrong che and
here wasn't much recognize that oh yeah
dude and he'd been like 13 years sober
and in my head I'd always kind of
thought you know I'm better than there
Oh strawberry you know like this guy I
can't you know
just not really I mean I always love
your I know but just somewhere in my
head like Oh Daryl struck but then here
he is like 13 years sober and eloquent
and successful in this and that and it
made me think made me kind of
re-evaluate some things and then also
the great comics right now or some of
the ones who are most successful are
sober yeah or don't party some you know
it's but then there's also guys like
Rogan you know who have you know huge
followings and Diaz and you who are ok
with party and they seem to manage it
you know but um but that's all about but
I get able to manage it yeah right I
feel like I felt a good rapport I did
wasn't managing it well was it affecting
your work when I showed up to that thing
and I was [ __ ] up right
I was like this is affecting my work
because if you'd asked me you earlier
hey dude will you show up at this radio
station tomorrow be like EIB love to
dude you know I'll go to bed early of
course because I'm going to be ready but
then here I was not in any good
condition I mean I've been actually to
be honest I was high on uppers and I've
been dry I've been actually driving a
tab met a taxi driver and he had met a
taxi driver met a taxi driver I got a no
attacks right and then he ended up we
ended up buying drugs together he ended
up buying me a prostitute
I don't like prostitutes I mean I
respect them wait wait wait wait no it's
my job wait wait wait wait wait you're
skipping some of these steps still yeah
how does that conversation start with
the cab driver I thought he said drugs
he said something else even speak
English he said hot language yeah he
goes said huh he was like you want a hug
and you're like yo Kane yeah yeah yeah
yeah your desires would be loved like
drug he could have said hippopotamus new
Beyonce drugs yeah I'm a bar G so anyway
we got the drugs he ended up buying out
it's be nice it's got luigia still texas
sometimes he bought you a hooker but not
one for himself yeah about me a hooker
and then we uh did did he say he said
hey man I got the drugs first and
he said let me get a hooker he said uh
no he surprised the talker oh my god
gift yeah oh it's like I got a gift for
you we're sitting in the back of the
taxi partying together he's like I got a
gift for you and I thought I was gonna
be some [ __ ] you know yeah like a broken
nose oh yeah so I'm practicing my like
see a [ __ ] don't be interest yes yeah oh
oh not tonight yeah state but uh but
next thing you know this hooker gets in
and um he sneak hooked you yeah he
cooked me but then I didn't want that
and the next thing you know he ends up
hooking up with the hooker I'm driving
the taxi so literally driving a taxi in
North hell they're [ __ ] in the
backseat they weren't [ __ ] but there
was some sexual interaction you know
they was really enjoying each other's
time and but yeah man so then I end up
at the radio station with Darryl
Strawberry
so like fast forward an hour and a half
I'm at the radio station we go
strawberry and that's when I was like -
what you know like everything in my life
is great but this seems to be a little
bit unmanageable at times so and a lot
of that just goes honestly back to me
being like you know I got like a lot of
just - just emotional issues or you know
if you're a commitment for your
rejection there's a lot of fear is
probably from growing up you know that
never did you have a mom and dad my dad
was 70 when I was woman that was really
old and then I had my mother but she
worked really hard so she didn't provide
much emotionally for us you know I mean
she could have been on welfare she chose
not to be on that she chose to work
instead but then you can't be there so
so you know it's just I grew up a lot of
times it's making choices for myself you
know and in like a brother sisters yeah
I got an older brother two younger
sisters and just scare and it was in a
scary neighborhood so I just grew up in
a lot of fear so I think a lot of that
resonated with me for a long time but um
but yeah so then I quit fast forward I
quit drinking about a year ago are you
better comic yeah I mean I had like a
number one album this year like we had
this album 30 pound bag of hamster bones
that was number one more charts for
almost a month
and by the way guys why I haven't asked
them to tell the hamster story is just
that like just go to Netflix
yeah or buy is out you can get the album
I got the special Netflix
but-but-but like that story will give
you an example of what I was telling you
about his storytelling abilities do
there like that's not a story anybody
else tells yeah yeah those hands man
slang enhance was and this back when you
didn't see people selling small ground
game in the middle of the night you know
what you still don't see much of it yeah
I guess I mean I don't think anyone
picked up your business they were like
yeah yeah
what's Neal's not in the hamster
business anymore like dude I
Lisa sell ma enhancers and G pigs and
they're beautiful look at that time what
did that sign say oh wow found hamster
okay and they spelled it right okay so
deal when we were living in Studio City
with the other white people right yeah
so I hate a hamster because they're
nocturnal they don't tell you that
they're gonna run that wheel at night oh
yeah not other in the dark arts I've
always said oh and they're creepy [ __ ]
right yeah they didn't used to be as
much but they've gotten creepy yeah
they're a little creepier yeah and I I
as a rule don't trust animals that walk
and [ __ ] at the same time yeah that's
not my like you horses
rabbits horses some Indian yeah yeah
yeah nummy yeah those people anybody
walk she's just the same time we're not
gonna be friends that's not you're not
in my I don't like it so um we had this
answer and I [ __ ] hated it
Jacob wasn't and I told Beth I'm like
I'm getting rid of this [ __ ] hamster
she was like the kids love it I'm like
nope
don't worry so Jacobs in the backyard
with his friend he's probably four maybe
five mm-hmm and he says to me hey can we
take the hamster out and play with them
backyard and I want yep because you know
at four or five your attention yeah I
mean that hamsters got what are you
going ten minutes yeah max and then I
don't have to live with the guilt he let
it go yeah you know I mean it's a good
parenting mm-hmm you know me yeah you
draw a picture of him Howard harvesters
draw pictures I'm letting it go yeah I
just put it on this wall and be like hey
did what happened yeah this is what
happens right life lesson Plus good for
me yeah so hamster gets away oh my god I
tell him you know what buddy it's
probably better he's gonna be out there
with all his hands or friends he goes to
live in the wild you know I mean yeah
there's a lot more opportunities out
there for him for romance yeah yeah he's
here by himself he's looking for love
he's out there looking for love but at
some point in his life he will be they
don't live long know it's about week
three they're usually looking for say
prey and I was thinking when we don't
live long I was probably thinking that
night yeah because there are now there
are a lot more termined a lot of owls
and then they would oh yeah well back to
that yeah right so two days later we
find that stuck to a telephone pole no
found hamster call and they have their
phone numbers up there and two phone
numbers and then what's the picture down
at the bottom what did somebody draw a
little hamster face you gotta take a
little hamster face so clearly whatever
little child found his hamster drew this
have you ever called them oh we call
them they wouldn't answer they were like
you know what how badly you want to
answer I'm like not at all we don't the
hamster at all no they can't be you know
what's with David the kid's name is kind
of fella it loves it I'm like you keep
the hamster yeah
but we're keeping the sign Wow the sign
was like it's the best because you would
have signed who thinks a hamster
survived a night in Studio City nobody
oh that's a great that's a great
animated series on the hamster gated
movie Camp is a Studio City the hamsters
do you know there are parrots that fly
around sir is it really yeah they're
parrot they're flowers at a flock
yeah on fleek they say no we compared it
yeah I know you got a jet tell everybody
and by the way man yeah I'd love to come
back next I know we gotta finish this
conversation yeah and I got to tell you
- so Sweeney he kept on the he was doing
the ghost and it was going well yeah
and then he left his ghost costume on
when Tommy was driving and they caught
him driving a Dodge Ram and they and
they busted him as the ghost yeah it was
like a school of real-life scooby-doo I
was like a real like everyday we would I
would have got away with it - they took
the [ __ ] pass got him even I get an
old man sweetie
who'd that's really caught a mousse in
the Dodge Ram driving with the thing I
guess he just got so in that world you
know living outside of himself and ghost
and that he started to see the world
through that and he drove home in it I
just ghost don't drive you're busted I
just picture home and Sweeney in the
glow-in-the-dark ghost costume that is
in all the Scooby Doo's and he's driving
but the noise like
whoo the best part is when they come up
to his window and they're like they're
like you know we've pulled you over for
tea still has no idea he's in the ghost
Gaza or maybe he's still playing ghost
whoo I'm not here you know yes
dude I am I would love you to come back
guys I can't tell you enough and also
man tell everybody about your podcast I
listened to your podcast thanks yeah
like I said man it's coming along we got
two podcasts one called allegedly and
that's with Hollywood types with me and
Matthew Cole Weiss and everyone called
this past weekend that comes out on
Mondays and let's talk about the weekend
and take callers from struggling adults
who are struggling with just all types
of stuff and then we try and just talk
about it this past weekend makes me
laugh man thanks man
really makes me laugh because it's a
hundred percent you yeah and like you're
like I said man what I think we'll
always what why I know you're going to
be successful is because you're a
hundred percent you yeah and the people
who are unabashedly hundred percent
themselves the the grab grab move Joey
yeah after fifty hit it but he never
stopped being himself right yeah and
people finally were like no dis dude
yeah the real deal and that's the thing
room the reason I'm a hundred percent
sure that you you are going to be at
that next level is a year one hundred
sent you on stage man there's nobody
that does anything close to it so guys
if you haven't heard of stand-up check
it out yeah yeah I appreciate that Josh
I really do me you always uh you know
you always have nice things to say you
genuine about it it's really felt
absolutely may I appreciate it yeah when
it just come out I'm gonna put it out
today how about though awesome dude yell
make sure to share it I'll be in uh can
I drop it drop them all drop mo I'll be
in San Diego July 20th with Sal Vulcano
you know Sal yeah man
at the House of Blues and then I will be
at the Addison improv in Dallas and that
is August 10th through the 13th I'm
really excited
two weeks after me everybody so I'll
make sure that I hire your student
mental
you're coming yeah when we're at the
show when I'm at the show make sure
everybody comes cool
yeah dude in eight years out before uh
and guys you know comedian Josh McCown
for tour dates my other podcast prints
in the wolf which when we start taking
guests I've already told Freddie bhaji
he wants you to come on dude yeah dude
this dude has stories like he's got
crazy oh yeah where he's a really
interesting guy
really it she got yeah not my shutter
for you guys man I love that name two
prints in the wolf so good you couldn't
have a better one no I have to admit
that one of our listeners and Brendan
Schaub both out
Brendan's [ __ ] great at that [ __ ] but
it's great yeah he's really interesting
dude and it was so much of a better
businessman than I am yeah I'm a
terrible businessman are you we get a
lot going on then you got to be you know
you got the family your wife you're an
actor you got you know you get a lot of
stuff to do do you want to have a family
you know yeah do you have a family I did
so I got a little bit of the demons any
well you know want to be out there
spraying out and you know chasing leg
and all of that and you know so it's a
battle you know it's because I don't
want to live you know I want to try and
live with a clean heart you know you'll
get to a point dude where you're just
tired of that yeah you'll know you'll
become point where your bed times
yes sometimes right I remember getting
to that point where I remember looking
at a woman and being more disgusted with
myself
the next morning than I was with her
where I was just like this is what the
[ __ ] you know what is it like that's not
like a thing is this it this can't be it
because it for a while when you're
younger dude you're like oh yeah oh yeah
I want to see you every vagina I can
possibly see yeah but then you're like
they're kind of similar yeah a lot of
the vaginas it's a lot of the same
framework yeah it's all cut out of the
same artwork yeah and then there's
anything there's Audi's yes kind of
prefab a lot of prefab badges dude
mom I say there's one thing animal as
you go when we were in Mexico once I had
brought my buddy would never been to a
strip club before
mm-hmm and a girl was with us and my
buddy I set him up I go when we walked
in I go sent back to the boom-boom room
the grossest we got right absolutely
gross
right and he said yeah so they grew yeah
yeah that he was like the gun best
looking gross or just gross I'm like
gross hey guys okay so and then me and
the girl are sitting there and she goes
what kind of happened back there I'm
like we're gonna find out right and then
this girl dancing on stage she's like
half of her away and I see the girl
squint like this and she goes what is
that what is that coming out of her
vagina and I was like that's her vagina
wow yeah oh we're like alien you know
alien had the second set of teeth oh
yeah yeah it was I was an Audi it was
like Homer Simpson sideways oh and there
and then some pajamas okay trying to
hand you some here you know and I'm
never really yeah that's fun you just
got to be ready to take a pan yeah yeah
you know I've always thought I didn't
know there's gonna be a hand out to this
session
okay thank you all right man thank you
very much for coming by we'll do it
again
- thank you man I love you and uh and uh
and thank you for just always including
me in your life somehow I'm excited to
know you dude absolutely man you're good
dude make us better better better better
better better better better better